con el peor inicio de temporada de
incendios forestales de su historia
Canadá pide ayuda a sus aliados el
miércoles Portugal se convirtió en el
último país en enviar un contingente de
bomberos en apoyo
Portugal ha expresado una vez más su
solidaridad enviando 140 bomberos
estarán sobre el terreno durante 15 días
Para apoyar a las fuerzas canadienses
Canadá lleva meses luchando contra una
oleada de incendios forestales cada vez
más agresivos y que están Arrasando sus
bosques ya se han quemado más de 13
millones de hectáreas una superficie
mayor que la de Países Bajos el
miércoles en la agencia de incendios
forestales del país informó que cerca de
460 incendios seguían activos
234 de ellos fuera de control el Primer
Ministro Justin trudó que se reunió el
miércoles con miembros de las fuerzas
armadas advirtió que la situación aún
puede empeorar obviamente estamos viendo
un aumento de los fenómenos astrológicos
extremos el aumento de los incendios
forestales en todo el país y lo haremos
en los próximos años debido a los
impactos de la crisis climática Así que
estamos discutiendo mucho sobre cómo
asegurarnos de que estamos preparados
para ello la mayoría de los incendios
fueron causados por fenómenos naturales
como tormentas sin embargo los
científicos han advertido que están
siendo aún más graves por la crisis
climática Y es que aunque los incendios
forestales de verano son habituales en
Canadá el alcance y el inicio del
desastre actual es que comenzó en marzo
han hecho que el país esté ahora en un
territorio desconocido